I am Erin forward and I am your Attorney
General I'm honored to be here today to
speak to you about Juneteenth today in
which accordance to our own state laws
passed by sponsored by and passed by
then a similar man Harvey Mumford a day
that we commemorate the abolition of
slavery in the United States
Jim taint has an interesting history and
while we celebrate in response to
President Lincoln signing the
Emancipation Proclamation it's important
to note that abolishing slavery was
somewhat of an afterthought if you know
me I just speak the truth
I appreciate the altruistic outcomes but
sometimes altruistic outcomes are
brought about as a matter of necessity
when the American Civil War started in
1861 President Lincoln made it clear
that his only goal at the time was to
preserve the Union in fact in a letter
to Horace Greeley who is the founder and
editor of the New York Tribune President
Lincoln said this and I quote my
paramount object in this struggle is to
save the Union
and it is not either to save or destroy
slavery if I could save the Union
without freeing any slave I would do it
and if I could save it by freeing all
the slaves I would do it and if I could
save it by freeing some and leaving
others alone I would do that too it
eventually obviously became obvious that
preserving the Union would mean the
destruction of slavery but during the
early part of the war captured slaves
were actually held as contraband of war
with the actual expectation that they
would eventually be returned to their
owners on January 1 1863 however
President Lincoln took the critical step
of issue
the Emancipation Proclamation the order
freed the slaves in areas occupied by
Union armies but it did not immediately
affect those who lived in the ten states
of the Confederacy and so on June 19th
this day in 1865 two and a half years
after the signing of the Emancipation
Proclamation the union's Major General
Gordon Granger arrived in Galveston
Texas with 2,000 federal troops he
assemble those who were present and he
read general order number three which
informed the people of Texas including
my fourth great-grandmother and my third
great-grandparents I imagine they were
in Texas at the time in accordance with
the Emancipation Proclamation that the
slaves for free as you might imagine the
damned former slaves received the news
of great joy spontaneously organizing a
celebration which was the first
celebration of the end of slavery in its
entirety in the United States as the
Union troops advanced the joyous news
reached more and more people one of them
you might note Booker T Washington he at
the time was a nine year old boy living
in Virginia and he recalled the events
as follows and I quote as the great day
grew nearer there was more singing in
the slave quarters than usual it was
bolder and more rain and lasted later
into the night most of the verses of the
plantation songs had some reference to
freedom some man who seemed to be a
stranger a union a United States officer
I presume made a little speech and then
read a rather long paper the
Emancipation Proclamation I think after
the reading we were told that we were
all free and could go when and where we
pleased my mother who was standing by my
side leaned over and kissed her children
while tears of joy ran down her cheek
she explained to us what it all meant
that this was a day for which she had
been so long praying but fearing that
she would never live to see since that
time June 10th has become an important
annual tradition in many parts of the
country it's a day to celebrate our
ancestors our heritage and our history
but as we celebrate June 10th today we
need to remember that the Emancipation
Proclamation and the victory of the
Union in the Civil War marked the end of
the institution of slavery but the
struggle for true freedom and equality
was just beginning we know this to be
true especially during these times we
are reminded and frankly I'm reminded
both mentally and physically I literally
have a headache and it won't go away the
recent killing of George Floyd at the
hands of police officers has reopened
wounds wounds that have never really
healed and in fact sometimes they
haven't even begun to scalp police
brutality against black Americans as
both age-old and current thus as a
member of law enforcement who
appreciates the sacrifice of my
colleagues and as a member of society
who believes in fairness and
accountability I embrace and acknowledge
the fact that conversations around
police reform or entirely appropriate
and timely but as I've said before the
time for conversing should be near over
if not already completed we should
already be seeing tangible policies and
the consistent enforcement of those
policies to create to restore in to
augment trust between members of law
enforcement and the communities that
they serve
indeed members of the public have the
absolute rights to believe that the type
of interaction that they experience with
law enforcement will not depend
the color of their skin in that if an
injustice occurs the response will be a
fair and impartial netting of justice
that's why I'm proud of the
conversations conclusions and
suggestions and solutions revealed thus
far during our panels up the justice and
injustice forum that I began a few weeks
back
many who have participated have outlined
policies they recommend it or have
already instituted in the wake of George
horse killing time which we do not have
and for which we should not have to wait
will tell if these forums will lead to
results I'm optimistic that said I'd
like to share my vulnerability during
these times like these every time this
happens and I get goose bumps you can
see them right now these are bad goose
bumps
they always caused me to exist in an
uncomfortable consistent persistent and
virtually perpetual state of anxiety in
part because I sense our country
simultaneously being on the precipice of
both progress and pandemonium and you
never know which way we're going to go
we're the protests in what's being
sought through them be considered and
received with open minds and thereafter
acting upon or will the naysayers and
those who oppose actual progress hone in
on the actions of a few who attempt to
co-opt the conversation to divert
attention away from it
to undermine it and to drown out the
concerns being raised will people and
politicians take these concerns
seriously and respond with changes in
the enforcement of laws policies and
practices or will they bide their time
and actually do what they've done before
which is wait for the fervor to die down
and simply continue with the status quo
again
only time will tell but honestly as we
as we wait for time to tell anxiety
continues to permeate parts of my my
life because I'm forced to renew my
personal concerns for my son's safety my
son's I have three of them and a nephew
that we've raised and I worry about
their safety in not to mention my wife's
and my sanity we're scared saw my sons
these are emotions I don't wish on
anyone yet these emotions are
consistently recurring and they appear
to be chronic in my life and I suspect
the lives of most black Americans to say
however that these concerns are born
purely out of personal or vicarious
experiences with law enforcement belies
the truth and it minimizes if not wholly
negates the fact that this is a systemic
problem we must address the fact that
we've created an entire criminal justice
system that statistics show for example
discriminatorily applies discretion
and/or benefit of the doubt when it
comes to whether an officer arrests an
individual whether a prosecutor charges
him and if so with what and if a judge
sentences him and if so to what reform
of the entire criminal justice system
therefore is a key and necessary
component of this conversation about
systemic racism but beyond the criminal
justice system we must also address the
fact that similar discriminatory
practices and policies in other aspects
of the system of our democracy contain
systemic racism as well to deny that
fact likewise negates the
well-documented discriminatory practices
that exist in our education economic
housing and employment systems just to
name a few
and it also ignores the fact that our
political system also shares blame
and perpetuating systemic racism I'm
about to share some things that may have
me losing friends maybe even some
acquaintances as well but some of our
elected leaders continue to contribute
to the problem either actively or
passively or wittingly or unwittingly
and sometimes all of the above I don't
have to talk about politicians outside
of Nevada to provide examples and
frankly I don't have to go back decades
to find these examples each event that
I'm about to describe to you has
happened that since I was first elected
to public office in 2012 in fact I wrote
about many of them in a 2013 opinion
piece that I wrote entitled a
conversation all too common I mean
speaking of slavery which today is the
day that we commemorate the abolition of
it consider the fact that I once had to
explain to my sons while a former
legislative colleague of mine was taped
saying that if his constituents wanted
him to keep vote to bring back slavery
the quintessential example of a racist
system
further consider that I've also had to
discuss with my sons while another
legislative colleague of mine would have
the audacity to as he says provocatively
right
in essence that blacks aren't grateful
enough to whites for the roles in ending
slavery and then consider that I also
had to talk to my sons about yet another
legislative colleague of mine who said
on the radio regarding an upcoming
election at the time that he actually
hoped that minorities and young folks
wouldn't vote even though exercising the
right to vote is undoubtedly one of the
best ways to help dismantle systemic
racism and then consider the fact that
each of these former colleagues of mine
were either or would later become
elected leaders of their legislative
caucus they maybe you'll understand a
little bit why I have this perpetual
headache to their credit the colleagues
about which I speak now apologized for
their comments two of them actually
apologized to me directly and one even
called me to ask that I relay his
apology to my sons
that's a judgment in my estimation was
so compromised that they could even
allow themselves to utter those words
however is problematic and in my
estimation it contributes to a systemic
racism in ways that we see and that we
don't see at the end maybe the aspirant
of equality will soothe my headache and
maybe one day I'll be able to cope
better right now though it feels like a
migraine and it keeps me up at night and
it wakes me up in the morning it's
unfair it's unjust it's improper and
it's problematic not to mention painful
now make no mistake about it I'll show
my vulnerability not to wine but to let
you know that I remain undaunted but the
showing today represents an opportunity
of a way forward and I'm encouraged by
you being here today to celebrate
Juneteenth and also to speak out against
recent events I ask that you continue
doing that and know that I stand with
you so again thank you for so much for
having me out Shelly Buerkle Thank You
total